das ist eine wirklich spannende
erkenntnisse sind es etwa die roten
zwerge in deren nähe sich außerirdisches
leben versteckt hält bisher galten sie
als lebensfeindlich doch ein us
forschungsteam hat jetzt herausgefunden
dass die strahlungs ausbrüche der roten
zwerge nicht unbedingt leben zeitlich
sind und sogar bei der suche nach aliens
super hilfreich sein könnten
zudem gibt es auch einen neuen
fachartikel zu dem mysteriösen
radiosignal unseres nachbar sterns dem
roten zwerg proxima centauri ist es nun
außerirdischen ursprungs oder eher nicht
clixoom sanchez uche gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen klicks so ist weiter
unter den top 40 podcast wissenschaft in
deutschland wie podcast jahr für
unterwegs nur zum hören im auto auf dem
fahrrad in der bahn gibt es clixoom auch
als podcast und ich kann nur da schmidt
zitieren ich liebe diesen podcast und
auch die videos sehr gut recherchiert
kurz und knackig unterhaltsam und
einfach schön kann ich nur jedem
empfehlen der physik astronomie und
wissenschaft im allgemeinen markt die
fülle der inhalte ist beeindruckt ich
würde mal sagen abspeichern für den fall
der fälle klickt auf die links zu
spotify und apple podcast in der video
beschreibung und hier unterm ihn manche
fachleute gehen davon aus dass es allein
in unserer milchstraße achtung 10.000
außerirdische zivilisation geben könnte
doch wie sehen diese aus und wo genau
halten sie sich versteckt jetzt haben us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neue forschungsergebnisse zu genau
diesen fragen veröffentlicht demnach
eröffnen sich ganz neue möglichkeiten wo
sich außerirdisches leben versteckt
halten könnte
denn bisher galten rote zwergsterne wie
bei proxima centauri wo der erste
kandidat für ein außerirdisches signal
bsc one her stammen soll als ziemlich
ungeeignet für eine zivilisation
denn die strahlungs ausbrüche dort die
sogenannten flyers könnten das leben
bereits im keim ersticken oder besser
verbrennen aber das umfeld der
sogenannten roten zwerge kommt der neuen
studie zufolge demnach für
außerirdisches leben sehr wohl in frage
und das obwohl es dort immer mal wieder
diese
heftigen strahlungs ausbrüche gibt und
fest steht die suche nach außerirdischen
läuft auf hochtouren und dennoch bislang
ohne erfolg denn trotz intensiver
forschungen konnten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler bislang nicht einmal
einfachste lebensformen auf anderen
himmelskörpern aufspüren ebenfalls
erfolglos blieb bislang die
identifikation von außerirdischen
lebenszeichen über radiosignale und auch
diesen spuren gehen einige
forschungsprojekte nach unter anderem
das sogenannte city projekt das schon
seit vielen jahren nach außerirdischen
sucht und ausgerechnet jetzt das
mysteriöse radiosignal wir hatten
darüber berichtet nach ansicht der seht
die forscherin sophia scheidt von der
pennsylvania state university das zitat
aufregendste signal dass wir im break
solisten projekt bisher gefunden haben
das signal von proxima centauri sorgt
seit wochen für aufregung und manche
fachleute hoffen dass es sich hierbei
tatsächlich um das erste künstliche
signal einer außerirdischen zivilisation
handelt jetzt hat sich der renommierte
harvard astrophysiker im loeb dazu
geäußert und das ist sehr spannend was
er zu sagen hat aber eine entscheidende
frage bei der suche nach außerirdischen
ist ja nicht nur nach wen genau wir
eigentlich suchen sondern vor allem auch
wo wir im besten fall suchen sollten
hier ist die fachwelt der ansicht das
leben wohl am wahrscheinlichsten dort
entstehen kann wo die folgenden
gegebenheiten zu finden sind flüssiges
wasser mit temperaturen die nicht so
sehr schwanken und ein magnetfeld denn
dieses könnte das außerirdische leben
vor der strahlung aus dem weltraum
schützen
zudem könnte so eine atmosphäre
existieren die gas zum atmen zur
verfügung stellt lange zeit gegen die
wissenschaft davon aus dass
außerirdisches leben wohl nur auf
erdähnlichen planeten existieren kann
in der sogenannten habitablen zone ihres
sterns mittlerweile wird das nicht mehr
so eng gesehen und die fachwelt geht
stark davon aus dass leben wohl auch in
scheinbar feindlichen umwelt ein
existieren kann beispielsweise in
gefrorenen eiswelten wasser planeten die
ganz ohne landmassen auskommen oder aber
auch extrem heißen gasriesen nur auf den
ersten blick scheinen sie zu trocken zu
kalt so gasförmig oder zu heiß zum leben
zu beherbergen aber eben nur auf den
ersten blick das beweisen die
sogenannten irdischen aliens die
beispielsweise kilometer tief im gestein
der erdkruste leben
ganz ohne sauerstoff unter großer hitze
unter druck und dem ewigen dunkeln und
es gibt weitere beispiele dafür dass
solche extremen bedingungen nicht
zwangsläufig das aus für leben bedeuten
müssen und auch die bedingungen um die
roten sterne herum galten für die
fachwelt bislang als absolut
lebensfeindlich und so wurden die
erdähnlichen planeten die sie umkreisen
als eine eher ungeeignete heimat für
potentielles leben gehalten eine extreme
einschränkung für die suche nach
außerirdischem leben denn tatsächlich
wurden die meisten ehrt artigen
exoplaneten innerhalb der habitablen
zone in den systemen dieser stern
kategorie aufgespürt doch fest steht
rote zwerge weisen eine extrem hohe
solare aktivität auf die zu einer
starken strahlungsbelastung für die rede
ist von der sogenannten flair aktivität
dieser sterne diese flairs meinen grob
gesagt aktivitäten auf der oberfläche
die von der so genannten konfekt even
schicht herrühren elektrisch leiten das
plasma bewegt sich und erzeugt
elektrische ströme die dann wiederum zu
magnetfeldern führen sobald eine
magnetische zone instabil wird wird die
im magnetfeld gespeicherte energie
schlagartig frei und das führt zu einem
auswurf von plasma in den weltraum
flairs produzieren also riesige mengen
an extremer uv und röntgenstrahlung
solche flash gibt es bei manchen roten
zwergen alle paar jahre nicht so aktiv
sind sie bei roten zwergen die langsam
rotieren und verhältnismäßig jungen sind
die meisten roten zwerg sterne aber sind
sehr aktiv deutlich aktiver als
sonnenähnliche sterne und das führt dazu
dass die umliegenden planeten oft mit
einer hoch energetischen strahlung
geflutet werden und diese strahlung ist
extrem
sie ist nicht nur in der lage vorhandene
atmosphäre zu zerstören auch die dann
völlig ungeschützten oberflächen dieser
planeten könnten durch sie angegriffen
werden dabei handelt es sich bei der
großen mehrheit aller sterne in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft um rote zwerge
der wohl bekannteste ist proxima
centauri der uns abgesehen von der sonne
so nah ist wie kein anderer sterne ist
nur 4,2 lichtjahre von uns entfernt
schätzung zufolge sind drei viertel
aller sterne rote zwerge und gemeint
sind damit die pflanzen und noch aktiven
sterne sie weisen nur etwa 1 bis 7
zehntel der sonnenmasse auf uns so läuft
die kernfusion
der roten zwerge auf sparflamme heißt
also im klartext rote sterne produzieren
wenig energie ihre oberflächen
temperaturen liegen bei 2400 bis 3.700
kelvin
das entspricht in etwa der temperatur
des glühfaden seiner alten glühlampe
heißt also es handelt sich um ziemliche
funzeln und selbst unser nachbar stern
proxima centauri ist so lichtschwach
dass wir ihn mit bloßem auge nicht
erkennen können doch auch er hat einen
planeten in der habitablen zone so auch
trapp ist eins der insgesamt über sieben
planeten verfügt von denen schätzung
zufolge zwei bis vier in der habitablen
zone liegen wie soll potenzielles leben
auf diesem planeten solche extremen
strahlungs ausbrüche überstehen und kann
sich leben bei solchen bedingungen
überhaupt entwickeln
ein us forschungsteam hat sich genau
diesen fragen gewidmet und hat in 3d
simulationen analysiert wie sich solche
flairs auf die atmosphärenchemie vom
planeten innerhalb der habitablen zonen
auswirken das ergebnis ist eindeutig
demnach ist solch ein extremes
weltraumwetter nicht das zwangsläufige
aus für die entstehung und entwicklung
von leben bei ihrer analyse haben die
forschenden die atmosphärenchemie
derjenigen planeten untersucht die
solchen ausbrüchen ausgesetzt sind diese
ergebnisse haben sie dann mit planeten
verglichen die eben keine oder nur
schwache stelara aktivität mitbekommen
dazu sagt der forscher horchen der an
der aktuellen studie beteiligt war
tatsächlich können gerade auch
fortwährende flairs eines sterns die
atmosphärische zusammensetzung eines
planeten in ein neues gleichgewicht
bringt aus diesem grund schließen
stelara ausbrüche auch nicht per se die
existenz von leben auf dortigen planeten
aus in einigen fällen führen selbst
stetige fluss nicht dazu etwa die
gesamte planet ozonschicht aufzulösen
leben auf dortigen oberflächen hätte
also weiterhin eine chance die
ozonschicht ist die schicht die das
tödliche uv-licht abhält und nicht nur
das das us forschungsteam kam weiterhin
zu dem ergebnis dass flairs sogar
hilfreich für unsere suche nach
außerirdischem leben sein könnten denn
sie könnten es erleichtern dieses leben
aufzuspüren und zu detektieren dazu das
forschungsteam so könnte es den anteil
eventuell vorhandener gase die auf leben
hinweisen
von einem unmerklichen auf ein
nachweisbares niveau anheben
diese emotionen der wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler legen also nahe dass
strahlungs ausbrüche die entstehung und
die entwicklung von außerirdischen leben
nicht per se ausschließen ganz im
gegenteil dieses weltraumwetter könnte
sogar dazu beitragen dass
forschungsteams weltweit die signaturen
von chemischen biomarkern auf einem
planeten besser identifizieren können
kurioserweise fast zeitgleich zu dieser
erkenntnis wurde auch das äußerst
rätselhafte signal von unserem nachbar
stern proxima centauri aufgespürt bsc
waren wir hatten ja bereits ausführlich
darüber berichtet das sorgt für
aufregung denn für natürliche quellen
scheint ist sehr ungewöhnlich so
mitgehen einige astronomie teams davon
aus dass es sich um radiosignale von
außerirdischen handel entdeckt werden
konnte es mit hilfe des parks
radioteleskops in australien und zwar im
rahmen eines strahlungsausbruch es von
einem zwang stern nämlich von proxima
centauri nach ansicht des
forschungsteams handelt es sich um eine
radium emission mit ungewöhnlich
geringer bandbreite die frequenz des
signals erscheint im wellen diagramm
scharf wie eine nadel und genau dieses
mal an dich kite lässt die fachwelt
aufhorchen denn das gilt als mögliches
charakteristikum eines künstlich
erzeugten signals denn in der natur
kommen solche schmalbandigen signale
nicht vor auch die frequenz sorgt für
aufregung denn in diesem bereich wird
nach außerirdischen signalen gesucht
heißt also im klartext dieses signal
entspricht allen kriterien eines
möglichen allen signals sophia scheidt
von der pennsylvania state university
sagt zu dem signal das auch die
bezeichnung break zu listen candidate
one bsi one getauft wurde
es ist das aufregendste signal dass wir
im bregtal listen projekt bisher
gefunden haben noch nie zuvor hatten wir
ein signal dass so viele unserer filter
überwunden hat sprich es hat bereits
alle strengen tests durchlaufen
darin wird geprüft stammt es von
satelliten die um die erde kreisen von
radiosendern auf der erdoberfläche und
und alles geprüft im moment gibt es
keine erklärung für das signal als die
das ist ein außerirdisches signal ist
aber eine gewissheit gibt es auch nicht
es könnte ja eine unbekannte irdische
quelle sein also was steckt wirklich
dahinter dazu hat sich jetzt der harvard
astronom abram löw geäußert
sein aufsatz ist online zu finden in
einem fachmagazin wurde
wer allerdings noch nicht veröffentlicht
aber er ist ja mit der leitung der
abteilung astronomie in harvard einer
der renommiertesten astrophysiker auf
der welt er hat das rätselhafte signal
zusammen mit seinem forschungsteam
genauer ins visier genommen in seinem
artikel äußert sich skeptisch und sorgt
somit wahrscheinlich für enttäuschung
unter allen elli [ __ ] näher nennt
mehrere punkte die seiner meinung nach
im großen und ganzen dagegen sprechen
dass es sich um signale einer
außerirdischen zivilisation handelt er
begründet das mit dem sogenannten
kopernikanischen prinzip fachleute
umschreiben damit die annahme dass der
mensch keinesfalls eine besondere
sonderstellung im universum einem
sondern die erde eben nur ein planet
unter vielen ist demnach sei es aber
trotzdem außerordentlich
unwahrscheinlich dass das signal
ausgerechnet von dem sterben system
kommt dass uns am nächsten liegt so
ähnlich hatte sich auch bereits der see
die forscher frank marx geäußert auch
wenn ich die vorstellung einer alien
zivilisation direkt vor unserer haustür
liebe scheint es doch hochgradig
unwahrscheinlich denn seiner meinung
nach wäre es doch wirklich kurios wenn
sich bei den angenommenen 300 millionen
potenzielle lebensfreundlichen exo
planeten in unserer galaxie zwei
zivilisation mit ähnlicher technologie
so nah beieinander liegen würden eher
blöd hält das mysteriöse signal also
eher für menschen gemacht er schreibt
dazu bsi wann stammt vermutlich von
einem von menschen konstruierten radio
oszillator auf der erde der die seiten
antennen des teleskops mit der
registrierten frequenz kontaminierte
also verunreinigte doch der hammer
forscher möchte auch nicht mit letzter
sicherheit ausschließen dass das bsi
warnsignal möglicherweise doch
außerirdischen ursprungs ist dabei
bezieht er sich auf die bewegung vom
planeten und sternen im all und die
annahme dass proxima centauri genau zu
jener zeit vermehrt nachbarn wurde als
die menschen auf der bildfläche
erschienen dazu erbringt
aufgrund ihrer zufälligen bewegungen
durch das all kommen sich sterne immer
wieder nah und entfernt sich auch wieder
voneinander interessanterweise wurde
proxima centauri etwa zu jener zeit zu
unserem nächsten nachbar stern als der
homo sapiens auf der erde erschienen ist
das also purer zufall oder aber
existiert doch intelligent
das leben auf proxima centauri das mit
dem leben auf der erde in verbindung
steht da wart forscher formuliert eine
klare aufforderung an die fachwelt das
nun aufgespürte signal zeige noch einmal
deutlich wie wichtig es sei unserem
nachbar systemen einen besuch
abzustatten als wissenschaftlicher
berater der breakthrough initiative star
schott ist das nicht verwunderlich
hierbei sollen miniatur sondern von
nicht segeln angetrieben werden und so
innerhalb von 20 jahren proxima centauri
erreichen er sieht vor allem den
planeten proxima b als mögliche heimat
einer möglichen außerirdischen
zivilisation dieser ist
höchstwahrscheinlich rotation geworden
an seinen stern sowie der mond an die
erde in den vorstellungen von apple mit
gibt es also eine seite des planeten die
ständig in die richtung des sterns zeigt
dazu schreibt er in einem kommentar für
die webseite des scientific american
sollte es also auf box thema b eine
zivilisation geben so könnte es sein
dass sie diese permanent zutage seite
großflächig mit sonnenkollektoren
bedeckt hat um so energie wärme und
licht auf die dauerhafte nachtseite zu
transferieren
mit genau dieser vorstellung beschäftigt
sich der harvard astronom der zeit
intensiver
dabei hat er nach eigenen angaben sogar
schon herausgefunden wie wir diese
künstliche beleuchtung der nach seite
vom proxima b als solche offenbaren
könnten der experte hält dafür dass
james webb weltraumteleskop als geeignet
diese soll im laufe diesen jahres ja
noch gestartet werden
das wird absolut also ich bin sowas von
gespannt auf die ersten bilder von james
webb weltraumteleskop mehr infos zu
bewahren gibt es hier ein signal wann
ist der erste offiziell anerkannte
kandidat anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren ihr habt ja das midi gehört
sehr gut recherchiert kurz und knackig
unterhaltsam und einfach schön und wenn
ihr das nicht mehr verpassen wollt dann
abonniert clixoom bis dann bleibt dran